Voiceover: In the last video, we took the
Maclaurin expansion of E to the X
and we saw that it looked
like it was some type a
combination of the
polynomial approximations
of cosine of X and of sine of X.
But it's not quite, because there's
a couple of negatives in there.
If we were to add these
two together that we
did not have when we took
the representation of E to the X.
But to reconcile these,
I'll do a little bit of a
I don't know if you can
even call it a trick.
Let's see if we take
this polynomial expansion
of E to the X, this
approximation, what happens
if we say E to the X is equal to this,
especially as this
becomes an infinite number
of terms and becomes
less of an approximation
and more of an equality.
What happens if I take
E to the IX and before
that might have been kind
of a weird thing to do.
Let me write it down, E to the IX.
Because before, I said how do you define
E to the Ith power?
That's a very bizarre thing to do,
take something to the XI power.
How do you even comprehend some type
of a function like that.
But now that we can have
a polynomial expansion
of E to the X, we can
maybe make sense of it.
Because we can take I to different amounts
to different powers and
we know what that gives,
I squared is negative one, I
to the third is negative I,
and so on and so forth.
So what happens if we take E to the IX.
So once again, just like
taking the X up here
and replacing it with
an IX, so every where
we see the X in it's
polynomial approximation,
we would write an IX.
So let's do that.
So E to the IX should be
approximately equal to,
and it will become more and more equal,
and this is more to give
you an intuition I'm not
doing a rigorous proof here,
but it's still profound.
Not to oversell it,
but I don't think I can
oversell what is about
to be discovered or seen
in this video, it would
be equal to one plus
instead of an X will have
an IX, plus IX, plus,
so what's IX squared?
So let me write this down.
What is IX squared over two factorial?
Well I squared is going
to be negative one,
and then you'd have X
squared over two factorials.
It's going to be minus X
squared over two factorial,
I think you might see
where this is going to go.
And then what is IX?
Remember everywhere we saw an X,
we're going to replace it with an IX.
So what is IX to the third power?
Actually let me write this out,
let me not skip some steps over here.
So this is going to be IX
squared over two factorial,
actually let me, I want
to do it just the way.
So plus IX squared over two factorial,
plus IX to the third over three factorial,
plus IX to the fourth over four factorial,
and we can keep going,
plus IX to the fifth
over five factorial, and
we can just keep going
so on and so forth.
Let's evaluate if these
IXs raised to these
different powers.
So this will be equal to one plus IX,
IX squared, that's the
same thing as I squared
times X squared, I
squared is negative one.
So this is negative X
squared over two factorial,
and this is going to be the same thing as
I to the third times X to the third.
I to the third is the same thing as
I squared times I, so it's
going to be negative I.
So this is going to be minus I times X to
the third over three factorial.
So then plus, you're going to have,
what's I to the fourth power?
So that's I squared squared.
So that's negative one
squared, that's just
going to be one.
So I to the fourth is one and
then you have X to the fourth.
Plus X to the fourth over four factorial.
And then you're going
to have, I don't even
write the plus yet, I to the fifth.
So I to the fifth is
going to be one times I,
so it's going to be I times X to the fifth
over five factorials plus
I times X to the fifth
over five factorial.
I think you might see a pattern here.
Coefficient is one, then
I, then negative one,
then negative I, then one,
then I, then negative one,
X to the sixth over six factorial,
and then negative IX to the seventh
over seven factorial.
So we have some terms,
some of them are imaginary,
they're being multiplied by I.
Some of them are real.
Why don't we separate them out?
So once again, E to the IX, is going to be
equal to this thing, especially as we add
an infinite number of terms.
Let's separate out the real
and the non-real terms.
Or the real and the
imaginary terms I should say.
So this is real, this
is real, this is real,
and this right over here is real.
And obviously we could
keep going on with that.
So the real terms here are
one minus X squared over two factorial
plus X to the fourth over four factorial,
you might be getting excited now,
minus X to the sixth over six factorial
and that's all I've done
here, but they would
keep going so plus so on and so forth.
So that's all of the real terms.
And what are the imaginary terms here.
And I'll just factor out the I over here.
Actually, let me just factor out.
So it's going to be plus I times,
well this is IX, so this will be X.
And then the next, so
that's an imaginary term,
this is an imaginary term.
We're factoring out the
I, so minus X to the third
over three factorial, and then the next
imaginary term is right over there.
We factor out the I,
plus X to the fifth over
five factorial and then
the next imaginary term
is right there, we factored out the I.
So it's minus X to the
seventh over seven factorial.
And then we would obviously keep going.
So plus minus keep going,
so on and so forth,
preferably to infinite
so that we get as good
of a approximation as possible.
So we have a situation where E to the IX
is equal to all of this business here.
But you probably remember
from the last two videos
the real part, this was the polynomial,
this was the Maclaurin
approximation of cosine
of X around I should say
the Taylor approximation
around zero or you could also call it the
Maclaurin approximation.
So this and this are the same thing.
So this is cosine of
X, especially when you
added an infinite power
of terms, cosine of X.
This over here is sine of
X, the exact same thing.
So it looks like we're
able to reconcile how
you can add up cosine of X and sine of X
to get something that's like E of the X.
This right here is sine of X.
And so if we take it for granted,
I'm not rigorously proving it to you,
and if you were to take an infinite number
of terms here that this
will essentially become
cosine of X and if you
take an infinite number
of terms here this will become sine of X.
It leads to a fascinating formula.
We could say that E to the IX, is the same
thing as cosine of X,
and you should be getting
goose pimples right around now.
is equal to cosine of X,
plus I times sine of X,
This is Euler's Formula.
And this right here is Euler's Formula.
And if that by itself isn't exciting and
crazy enough for you,
because is really should be.
Because we've already done
some pretty cool things.
We're involving E, which we get from
continuous compounding interest.
We have cosine and sine
of X, which are ratios
of right triangles, it comes
out of the unit circle.
And some how we've
thrown in the square root
of negative one.
There seems to be this
cool relationship here.
But it becomes extra
cool, and we're going to
assume we're operating in radians here.
If we assume Euler's Formula, what happens
when X is equal to pi?
Just to throw in another
wacky number in there.
The ratio between the circumference and
the diameter of a cirle.
What happens when we throw in pi?
We get E to the Ipi is
equal to cosine of pi.
Cosine of pi is what?
Pi is half way around the unit circle,
so cosine of pi is negative one and then
sine of pi is zero, so
this term goes away.
So if you evaluated at pi
you get something amazing,
it's called Euler's Identity.
I always have trouble pronouncing Euler's.
Euler's Identity, which
we could write like this,
or we could add one to both sides and
we could write it like this.
And I'll write it in
different colors for emphasis.
E to the I times pi plus one is equal to ,
I'll do that in a neutral color,
is equal to, I'm just
adding one to both sides
of this thing right over
here, is equal to zero.
And this is thought provoking.
I mean here we have, this
tells you that there's
some connectedness to the universe that we
don't fully understand or at least I don't
fully understand.
I is defined by engineers
for simplicity so that
they can find the roots of
all sorts of polynomials.
As you could say the square
root of negative one.
Pi is the ratio between the circumference
of a circle and it's diameter.
Once again another interesting number but
seems like it comes from
a different place as I.
E comes from a bunch of different places.
E you could either think of it comes out
of continuing compounding interest,
super valuable for finance.
It also comes from the
notion that the derivative
of E to the X is also E to the X,
another fascinating number.
But once again seemingly
unrelated to how we came
up with I and seemingly unrelated
with how we came up with pi.
And then of course you
have some of the most
profound basic numbers right over here.
You have one, I don't have to explain
why one is a cool number.
And I shouldn't have to explain
why zero is a cool number.
And so this right here connects all
of these fundamental
numbers in some mystical
way that shows that there's some
connectedness to the universe.
So frankly, if this
does not blow your mind,
you really have no emotion.